the left-hander brett anderson making
his third start of the year against
cincinnati yeah back to back against the
reds only three innings five hits five
runs
starts out with a strikeout
way to open up for brett anderson
a couple of strikeouts to open up his
appearance
didn't strike anybody out in three
innings as you mentioned rock last time
and he's working that change up pretty
well to these righties
and for brett anderson he's gonna have a
clean one two three
top of the first couple of spike outs
and routine fly ball brewers going to
work on offense when we come back the
rejuvenated right-hander luis castillo
he's been better three straight starts
on the ground of the second baseman far
to his left india gloves and throws in
time and urias is quickly gone one away
here in the first inning that'll bring
up daniel vogelback
oh foul tip 98 castillo moving out in
out with a lively fastball
right to farmer
castillo works around the two out walk
zeroes through one
[Music]
ground ball left side backhand stab
adamus jump throw
got him what a pick from vogelback and
the arms straight from adamus
how about that play by willie
what a play how about the throw the jump
throw to first
not many guys had the arm strength to
make this play
check swing he went around
scott heineman is out on strikes third
strikeout for brett anderson
[Music]
ground ball through the right side and
there goes your no hitter your pitchers
are always tracking that aren't you
swinging to miss
anderson strikes out india
same book that anderson gave india in
the first
back with a 2-2 swing and a miss
threw that right by him fastball over
the outside corner one down
and strength recall fastball right down
broadway two down two down in the inning
and castillo back to the dish ground
ball suarez he's got it he throws tavato
in time
three up three down for the ribs
right-hander luis castillo
aquino to short
easier play this time for adonis loads
up and fires a dart to vogelback
[Applause]
[Music]
roller to third
fair ball ureas unloads quickly
yeah his throws from third and second
have been much better than his throws
from short
gone away a little bit checking on urias
again
three ground ball outs ho-hum from brent
anderson clean top of the fourth
if we knew then what we know now
there's strike three on the inside
corner season high five strikeouts
from brett anderson
struck him out
two more strikeouts in this fifth inning
for brett anderson he is on a roll
tonight
there's a shot into the gap in right
center field castiano is able to cut it
off and hold narvaez
to a long single
first hit of the game for the brewers
double play ball
six
four
three
one two strike three called
[Applause]
seventh strikeout for brett anderson and
it starts
this sixth inning two base runners
against anderson in the game
and aquino strikes out swinging
eight strikeouts for brett anderson
through six
and he just walked jackie bradley junior
to open up the sixth
[Applause]
two two
strike three get serious looking
four strikeouts for castillo
them out
a delayed call
back to back backward k's
castillo and company strand bradley 90
feet away
scoreless still
thank you sophia ground ball hit towards
short adamus has it throws to first
vocal back scoops that one too
one pitch and one out here in the
seventh and he gets through castiano's
check swing got him there
another three up three down inning for
brett anderson strikeout number nine for
the brewers southpaw full on yelich for
a second time
and he strikes him out fastball in
carves up yellage that's three straight
strikeouts all looking
to third checking on suarez bearham
pickup throw to first off the bag it
gets away from vato
garcia contend at first base
poke down the left field line a fair
ball
garcia digging for third he'll put on
the brakes late
good decision aquino got to it quickly
the play was in front of him first and
second one away
they're loaded
strike three called he leaves him loaded
and winker pokes it to center gets on
down base hit
only the second hit of the night for the
reds he's a one-out runner
two-two to naked
struck him out of the changing
williams gets the job done
[Music]
swing at the miss
challenges and overwhelms the pinch
hitting robertson one down
and he gets him looking a perfect eighth
from brad brock and it remains scoreless
and yesterday off of course but you know
good numbers for josh has not blown a
save
and he walks jonathan india
right back to it strike three i don't
throw anything else
a little bit higher every time see he's
gonna chase it
he did
sliders struck him out
pure filth from josh hayder
no way you hit it the only thing you can
do is take it
runner goes throw down to second base
got him he was able to hang on
and apply the tag on india and in the
inning
india doesn't believe it he's still
standing at second base david bell says
no
and that's how the inning ends
throw on the first base side of the bag
urea's catch tag
no doubt about it nice
3-1
ball four lead off man is on
best base runner the brewers have
runner off
extra headaches
up and in
stevenson's on
he's been wearing it tonight a couple of
foul balls off his
hand and wrist
payoff
inside to walk the faces loaded
way inside and hit him for a run
suarez hit by pitch
base is still loaded nobody out and the
reds have the first run of the game in
the 10th one to nothing one down for
kyle farmer reds still have only two
hits one belongs to farmer
lifted to right
stevenson at third
gotta see on the glove stevenson tags
throw into the play
safe slide zach fly rbi
and a two-nothing lead as farmer
delivers again and now there's two down
for daniel robertson so now 3-2
[Applause]
flared to right that is going to get
down base hit but thomas is going to
come around and score as the ball gets
away from castiano's robertson's into
second there you go
that'd be a base hitting rbi and error
on castianos to allow roberts to get
into scoring position
that's a nice battle by daniel robertson
with two strikes
the payoff
slider didn't fish for it and now the
winning run is on
tying and winning runs on
[Applause]
check swing did he go
yes and the reds win it
garrett strikes out ropes the reds take
it in 10. they have the most extra
ending wins in baseball and they are red
hot